JOSE FLORES, JR.
HE WAS 10 YEARS OLD.
HIS FAMILY SAYS HE WAS AN
AMAZING SON AND BIG BROTHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Reporter: 10-YEAR-OLD JOSE
FLORES JR. HAD A HUGE SMILE ON
HIS FACE WHEN HE RECEIVED THIS
HONOR ROLL CERTIFICATE AT SCHOOL
ON TUESDAY.
JUST A FEW HOURS LATER, THE
WORLD CHANGED.
THIS IS HIS MOTHER, FATHER, AND
THREE SIBLINGS.
JOSE FLORES SR. WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL HOPING HIS SON WAS A
PATIENT THERE.
HE SAYS A NURSE TOOK HIM INTO A
HOSPITAL CHAPEL.
>> WHAT DID THE NURSE TELL YOU?
>> AS SOON AS THEY TOOK ME TO
THE ROOM, I ALREADY KNEW WHAT IT
WAS ABOUT.
SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO SAY MUCH.
THE WAY SHE TOOK ME IN THERE,
THE WAY SHE SAID, HAVE A SEAT.
WE WANT TO TALK TO YOU.
WE GOT TO TELL YOU SOME THINGS.
I MEAN I ALREADY KNEW WHAT WAS
NEXT.
>> Reporter: JOSE JUNIOR, A
LOVING SON AND BIG BROTHER, DID
NOT SURVIVE THE GUNMAN'S
RAMPAGE.
JOSE SENIOR CALLED HIS WIFE,
CYNTHIA.
>> HE JUST SAID, MY BABY DIDN'T
MAKE IT.
>> Reporter: IT SEEMED LIKE A
NIGHTMARE.
JOSE SENIOR AND CYNTHIA JUST
COULDN'T COMPREHEND THEIR ELDEST
CHILD WAS GONE.
JOSE SENIOR ASKED SOME TEXAS
RANGERS AT THE HOSPITAL IF HE
COULD SEE HIS SON.
>> ONE OF THE RANGERS TOLD ME --
CAME TO ME.
HE'S LIKE, AS A FATHER, I
WOULDN'T LET YOU GO BACK THERE
AND SEE HIM BECAUSE HE WAS NOT
RECOGNIZABLE.
>> Reporter: JOSE JUNIOR'S
5-YEAR-OLD BROTHER JADEN TOOK US
INTO HIS BEDROOM THAT HE SHARED
WITH HIS BIG BROTHER.
ON JOSE JUNIOR'S BED, ALL HIS
FAVORITE STUFFED ANIMALS FROM
WHEN HE WAS A LITTLE BOY AND A
SET OF CLOTHES THAT HIS PARENTS
SAY HE WILL WEAR IN HIS CASKET.
>> I DIDN'T GET TO HOLD HIM NO
MORE.
I DIDN'T GET TO SEE HIM.
JUST AT THE FUNERAL.
IT MIGHT NOT BE AN OPEN CASKET
FOR THE SAME REASON.
>> Reporter: JOSE JUNIOR WANTED
TO BE A POLICE OFFICER WHEN HE
GREW UP.
HE WANTED TO PROTECT OTHERS,
ESPECIALLY HIS BABY BROTHER,
JACE.
>> WHEN IT WAS JUST ME AND HIM,
HE'S SO GOOD, HE'S HELPFUL,
HELPING AROUND THE HOUSE.
HE WOULD JUST BE LIKE MY LITTLE
SHADOW.
LIKE HE WOULD JUST BE HELPING ME
AND STUFF, LIKE, WITH THE BABY.
HE HAD A THING WITH BABIES, LIKE
MY FRIENDS' BABIES.
HE'S JUST VERY GOOD WITH BABIES.
HE WAS ALWAYS NICE.
>> Reporter: WHEN JACE GROWS UP,
YOUR LITTLE BABY, WHAT DO YOU
TELL JACE ABOUT HIS BROTHER,
JOSE?
>> HE REALLY LOVED HIS LITTLE
BROTHER.
HE LOVED HIM.
HE WAS A LITTLE HELPER.
>> Reporter: ANDREA IS NINE
MONTHS YOUNGER THAN JOSE JUNIOR.
WHAT DID YOU LIKE MOST ABOUT
YOUR BROTHER?
>> THAT HE WOULD ALWAYS SUPPORT
ME, AND HE WOULD ALWAYS PLAY
WITH ME.
>> Reporter: ANDREA AND JOSE
JUNIOR WERE BOTH IN FOURTH GRADE
IN THE SAME SCHOOL.
SHE LIVED THROUGH THE SAME
HORROR BUT WAS IN A DIFFERENT
FOURTH GRADE CLASSROOM.
>> THERE WAS JUST A BUNCH OF
GUNSHOTS GOING THROUGH THE
WINDOWS AND DOORS AND A BUNCH OF
KNOCKING AND BANGING.
>> Reporter: THE EMOTIONAL
CHALLENGES ARE MANY FOR THIS
FAMILY.
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR SON AND
BROTHER, BUT THEIR MEMOR